There are websites dedicated to spotting mistakes
made in popular films and these mistakes are
usually inconsistencies between cuts.
Did you know that inconsistencies could happen
in animated films too?
It’s a lot of fun catching these rare occurrences
and we would love to hear about the ones we
didn’t show you today.
Add a comment for your favorite mistake in
a Disney films below and stick around to the
end of the video for a Frozen fact that you
might not have known.
Here is Screen Rant’s list of ten Disney
Animation Mistakes That Made The Final Cut.
Wreck-It-Ralph
When Vanellope is taught to drive with the
help of Ralph, she looses a tooth.
She spits it out and gives us a big smile
letting us know she lost that tooth but later
on it reappears.
With all the sugar and candy throughout the
lands they are visiting we are certain there
must be at least one dentist.
There was probably a deleted scene of her
going to the dentist and getting a crown.
That’s why she has that adorable smile again.
The Little Mermaid
Working with kids or animals are difficult
and any director will agree with that statement.
Before Prince Eric is presented with his unflattering
statue, his dog, Max heads over and licks
Ariel on the face.
On the right check to be exact but when Max
is called back by Eric.
Ariel turns around and touches her left check,
remembering the slobber just left there on
the wrong side.
Animals can be a distraction on sets and even
a half fish, half women actresses can get
distracted by animals.
Toy Story
Getting ready to be tortured by Sid, Woody
calls on Sid’s abused toys to help him save
his friend Buzz.
On the wall behind him is a clock that reads
3:10.
Moments later when the toys are getting ready
to execute Woody’s plan the clock reads
10:00.
You could say it was hours later but unless
they live in Alaska the sun should not be
shining still.
We think one of the animators had a little
fun and changed the time on us to see if we
were watching.
Lilo & Stitch
In one of the opening scenes, Lilo takes hula
lessons as two men beat on drums for rhythm.
It is quite impressive how they keep their
pace, especially impressive for the guy on
the right.
In between shots he changes his drum.
Originally they both had yellow drums but
then the guy on the right changes his drum
out for a Pahu.
We are going to blame this one on the property
master on the set; he probably missed a day
of work for some surfing lessons.
Frozen
There is a lot of magic going on in Frozen.
We have magic ice coming from fingertips and
a giant snowman that tries to eat people but
not every character has magical powers.
Hans doesn’t have magical powers but the
actor must have felt jealous of this oversight
so he added his own.
During the film he takes out a sword numerous
times to battle or to be threatening, but
where is it coming from.
It magically appears and disappears throughout
the film just like his love for Anna.
Monsters Inc.
When Monsters, Inc. scarer George exits a
kid's room he has a near-death experience.
A human child’s sock is attached to his
back!
Code 23-19, alert the CDA!
As the Child Detection Agency arrives and
causes chaos the sock flips from pointing
to the middle of his back to pointing to his
shoulder.
Maybe this mishap has to do with the same
sock Monster that steals my socks from the
dryer.
A mystery that will never be solved.
Beauty and the Beast
If you are going to get into an argument with
a Disney character, make sure it isn’t the
Beast from 1991’s Beauty and the Beast.
He has a temper and in the beginning of the
film when he looses that temper he slashes
a painting of his human self, going downwards
from left to right.
Later on when Belle strolls into the forbidden
wing of the castle the painting has different
slashes.
These slashes go down from right to left.
Maybe the Beast has numerous paintings of
himself and claws them frequently.
Toy Story 2
During the commercial for Al’s Toy Barn,
Rex stumbles with the remote to turn off the
television, luckily Ham comes over and helps
before anyone hears the commercial.
Strangely, when the TV is turned off there
is no reflection of Ham or Rex.
Are Ham and Rex vampires and that’s why
we can’t see their reflection?
Rex has the teeth but Ham still looks too
innocent for us to believe that.
Maybe we’ll find out in Toy Story 4.
Aladdin
When Jafar holds Princess Jasmine captive
she has to try and convince him that she is
in love with him.
How could a woman not fall for his charm?
On her right arm is a gold bracelet as she
tries to seduce him.
Once Jafar realizes it is a trick he pushes
her down and the bracelet is now on the left
arm.
Was this magic from the Genie or did the animators
make a mistake?
We think it was the Genie, only because we
love Robin Williams and are hoping for a deleted
scene that explains
this one-day.
Tangled
In the climactic scene when Flynn cuts off
Rapunzel’s outrageously long hair his right
wrist is visible and shackle free.
Then in the next shot his wrist is bound again
in shackles.
It looks like Flynn was having a hard time
deciding if he should be imprisoned or not.
At least when Rapunzel’s hair changes colors
it was on purpose even though it would have
been cool if it turned purple.
What do you think of our video?
Did we skip over any other of your favorite
Disney Animation Mistakes That Made The Final
Cut?
Sound off in the comments below and be sure
to subscribe to our channel!
Make sure to watch another Screen Rant video
for more fun lists of your favorite films
and actors!
Thanks for watching!